hello everyone we'll be focusing on what
a Java programmer or developer is in
this video in this video we'll be going
through what is Java why use Java where
can Java be used who is a Java developer
what they need to be good at the
responsibilities and how you can get
better at Java it's hard for someone
who's even remotely interacted with the
IT industry to not have heard of Java so
let's ask what is Java the whopping 9
million users and Counting Java which
was initially known as oke is something
that is taking the world of software
development by stop
Java which was based on C or C++ is a
programming language that is class-based
concurrent and based on the principles
of object-oriented programming with the
slew of new features the Java 8 and 9
brought out the language was
significantly changed enough so that
most multinational corporations like
Amazon Flipkart and Goldman Sachs use
Java for their large-scale projects but
why should someone consider using Java
in the first place here's why it's a
stable language with proven track record
and established best practices backward
compatibility code that was written in a
much earlier version can still be worked
on in the latest version ability to work
in large teams static typing interfaces
and design patterns make it very easy to
use Java in engineering teams versus
Python Ruby and JavaScript immediate
hiring there would be more number of
jobs in Java quality jobs large number
of jobs requiring to design complex
systems use Java few areas where Java
has been successfully implemented are
Android applications web applications
trading applications Big Data
technologies payments ecommerce and so
much more so who's a Java developer this
term is interchanged with Java
programmer from one organization to the
other a Java developer is a programmer
who specialized in integrating Java in
software's websites and business
applications a developer must be able to
understand the clients vision about a
particular project
and devised an appropriate course of
action to follow to determine whether
the finished product satisfies the
customer's requirements and if any
issues exist to solve them quickly to
deploy the product Accord in to a live
environment what do you need to make
your resume is standard from the several
others vying for the same position this
is what gives you the upper hand being
up to date with new features then each
progressive update to Java brings did
you know that Java 9 brings features
like the J shell process API and micro
benchmarks ensuring more versatility and
further customization being well-versed
in IntelliJ or eclipse knowledge in
these concepts increases productivity
dramatically also having skills in the
following is a huge plus Spring
Framework using its portfolio projects
several of the modern business
requirements can be satisfied
springboard
helps simplify the bootstrapping and
development of a new spring application
test-driven development to repeat a very
short development cycle to help increase
productivity and quality system design
Java is frequently used to design
large-scale complex systems the ability
to design systems well is very critical
for employability as a Java software
development engineer especially for more
senior roles object oriented analysis
and design a method where the logical
components form the basis on which an
application is analyzed and designed
relational databases SQL an object
relational mapping relational databases
it is a unified set of various sets
coordinated as it Accords tables and
columns SQL it is a language that can be
used to communicate with the database
object relational mapping it is a
technique that uses object-oriented
programming languages to convert data
between systems that are incompatible
with each other other areas that can be
focused on are EJB which is enterprise
javabeans java based web services j2ee
framework and xml xqe and XSL so what
does a Java developer do
assistant activities that involve the
software and architecture design
implement and maintain the many faces of
a java application analyze the software
perform programming testing and
debugging determine application issues
in regards with production and otherwise
develop test and maintain the software
recommend changes in the already
established java application process
develop code for applications lack the
required skills don't worry we've got
you covered with an emphasis on
everything about java the courses core
java training and advanced java training
in simple and calm is a great starting
point for students who have some
understanding of the core java concepts
or for professionals who seek to gain
more exposure and understanding into the
world of java we have students and
professionals understand concepts such
as scope of variables operators arrays
loops methods constructors ring
frameworks hibernate and so on the
course also helps in gaining hands-on
experience in JDBC and j-unit framework
helping you get the upper hand in a
world of competition hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here